hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's Kitchen in beautiful Prince
Edward Island
let me show you my very unglamorous
anesthetic on that girl unroutine a
morning routine while I'm here on
vacation with my family let's do it
let's do this so unlike every other
influencer here on YouTube
I don't usually like start my day with
fresh squeezed lemon juice to like detox
my body or like get my digestion going
or whatever
um I start with whatever I had started
the night before so it looks like I have
a nice selection here of bevies
a little bit of San Pellegrino obviously
finish that
I have
this
paper kind of the flow water that has
cucumber and mint
refreshing
I really like the flavor and I like that
it's not plastic but I don't give a [ __ ]
that it's alkaline water is it alkaline
yes this is alkaline Spring Water don't
care about that
and
some
OG tap water
and honestly Pei tap water is
Next Level good it's the best
no need to get fancy here folks
I've already had to warm this up like
three times
so I don't know if you can hear that but
it's raining really hard here today and
actually this is the first rainy day
that we've had so I guess we should be
grateful but it's gonna be rough because
in addition to not really being able to
go outside and just do our thing on the
beach or go biking or whatever to keep
these kids busy when it's raining the
internet also doesn't really work oh
she's she's storming so yeah I think
we're gonna have to just be creative
this morning to keep these kids out of
trouble okay
stop fighting no no oh my goodness
okay you got a bunny you've got a train
we're gonna have a race
God
it's too early for this
are you ready are you just laying down
hey you're sabotaging hey hey hey mind
your own vehicle
if I try to draw the curtains
aesthetically like an influencer this is
what I see
tell me you're an insomniac without
telling me you're an insomniac so I've
taken the kids since like five o'clock
so now that my hubby is up and ready and
trying to keep them busy I'm gonna get a
quick little
stretch slash workout in nothing crazy
but just kind of want to move my body
foreign
some 80s Vibes here with these ankle
weights
they do the trick
okay so I don't really wear any makeup
here just very little the bare minimum
um but I got a zoom call today so I want
to look semi presentable but the most
important thing in my morning routine
any day anywhere especially in the sun
is some kind of sun sunscreen this one I
just got from Sephora and I like it a
lot it's called biosance I don't know
the ingredient is just zinc oxide so it
seems like a good option 30 SPF which is
probably fine for a day like today and
I'll just make sure to reapply as often
as I need to
then I'll just do a little bit of my
Nars now you guys have all told me that
I'm supposed to not like sweep I'm just
supposed to like dab it
but you know what guys that takes a long
effing time and I don't always have time
for that so I am going to make you guys
all really pissed off at me and get this
effing job done faster because I can
hear my kids screaming and they probably
want me and they probably are hungry and
my husband probably like when is she
gonna be done so let's get it done super
quick this just like makes me feel a
little bit more alive in the morning and
mascara and I think that's probably all
I'm gonna do because I'm
Pi is not the place for full Glam good
enough also note to self don't bring
white shirts to Prince Edward Island
because it gets everything just gets
stained by the Red Sand so this is now
like a
like a pink orange shirt oh and by the
way I do bathe but I usually have my
shower at the end of the day because I'm
just gonna get gross and sweaty and wet
throughout the day here I also gotta
take all of my supplements and
medication
I'm not gonna be able to tell you what
all these things are because I put them
in my pill packs before I travel but I
know this is
um berberine and oregano this one's
oregano I think for my um sibo I've got
this kind of IBS
um capsule which is really good for my
digestion it's got like peppermint in it
um this is zinc this is D this is
omega-3 this
I don't oh B6 complex maybe that's the
oregano oh God one of them is my
digestive enzymes and one of them's
maybe magnesium nope take that at night
I can't even tell you but the rest are
also probably for my IBS and then I take
my anti-anxiety Med
Bottoms Up
don't even have water here I'm gonna
have to dry scoop it no I will take
these with water
just put a load of laundry on probably
you should have washed my sweaters clear
all pretty dirty all right it's all good
and I'm gonna go make some pancakes for
breakfast
thank you
so my little like pancake hat because I
always like to add a little bit of
cottage cheese in there it just bumps up
the protein and I love the texture
um it's super delicious especially with
lots of maple syrup and chocolate chips
um and I got this pancake mix which was
like a whole grain red Fife pancake mix
that's made locally
um and I got it at this like little
Artisan Stand just down the street so
cute and I love to buy all the local
products whenever I can
um
and these local strawberries also just
hit different
steak
can I help you
we are stuck inside because it's
currently raining but it's definitely
going to clear up a little bit later so
it's gonna be a two coffee kind of
morning
okay so while it's still kind of
drizzling I'm gonna just start to work
on lunge that way it's done and we can
just eat when we're ready and then enjoy
the rest of our day
foreign
before the morning is over I'm going to
quickly put together a lunch and it is
Cottage life here so of course we're
going with a little boxed mac and cheese
I'm very disappointed that I
accidentally was given the gluten-free
variety
and I also was hoping for like the
little bunnies because the kids like
that more however we're gonna make do
and again I got some tips so basically
I'm going to throw some chopped chicken
and broccoli in two hours as well as a
little scoop of some more cottage cheese
because I've got the end of the
container and I might as well use it up
and add some more protein and cheesy
flavor what's not to love I just tasted
the rice pasta and I hate to waste food
but I had to toss it it was terrible it
literally tasted like eating like
gum
so thankfully
we got this so we're gonna do a quick
little swap mac and cheese take two
[Music]
[Music]
this has been such a struggle of a
morning here because basically it's been
pissing rain all day we're in a very
small little cottage and when it's
raining the internet also doesn't work
yeah so that means no Netflix to
entertain my two very antsy children
oh
we had a little bit of an accident back
there it's gonna be okay but anyways I
am very excited for this ring to clear
up because usually by now we would have
spent the entire morning outside getting
their sillies out biking building sand
castles we're running amok you know it
but instead we've been doing crafts and
chasing each other in circles and doing
pretend competitions and having baths in
the morning even though we just woke up
and we had a bath before bed just things
to keep them occupied
but you know to his life to his
Parenthood and you gotta kind of roll
with the punches sometimes but it looks
like we're getting a little bit of a
break here in the rain so before we all
sit down to lunch I'm probably gonna try
to get outside just to like get some
fresh air before we get another
trenchild downpour Pi weather is so
funny they say if you don't like the
weather wait five minutes because it's
constantly changing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to my poor and shoddy interpretation of
the radar I have about 15 minutes to get
a little bit of fresh air in before we
get another damn pour so I'm gonna go
for a quick little walk on the beach
then head back up do a loop back on the
road and try to get back before I get
soaked
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well looks like I misjudged that one I
need to revisit my training on how to
read a radar but I've got a quick little
call here with my team my kids are
already having their lunch so I'm gonna
catch up with them afterwards and eat
whatever they've left me probably some
salad and macaroni and cheese and that's
the end of my morning so guys I hope you
enjoyed this really random Vlog I think
it's pretty safe to say that I don't
have a that girl routine nor do I really
have a strict routine every single day
of my life is gonna look different so
every single morning looks different as
well and that goes for whether I'm on
holiday or when I'm at home if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below with other
ideas for Vlog content you'd like to see
me do subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign